Ryan is with us in Ohio hi Ryan how are
you I'm doing well how you do need
better than I deserve what's up
so with this crisis going on my hours
are getting cut
I am completely debt free except for my
mortgage I owe about 60 grand left good
I have an emergency fund of 15,000 just
at the end of the last year I sold a
rental property and now I have $7,000 in
after taxes though what do you make a
year
let me up I need my wife made about 90
okay and what's your worst case scenario
on your income through the corona crazy
I really don't know well I mean
realistically what do you think is gonna
happen to your job I think it will get
cut Pass cut in half I think I take a
lot for ya worst case it would take a
lot for us to close yeah and how much is
your how much of the 90 is you know it
today I make 60 okay so you could go
from 60 are from 90 down to 60 if we
lost half of your 60 what about her job
I think she done pretty good she's in
profit you think she's stable yeah she's
in a non-profit yeah why would that be
stable I would guess I would guess the
charitable giving will dry up to nothing
for a little while
I just think their budgets already said
so they're funded for the entire year
okay all right so that'll keep that
pretty calm okay so if you went so I
pretty much you think are realistically
our worst-case scenario is your
household income goes from 90 to 60 you
have $15,000 in the bank and you have
$70,000 in the bank and you have a
$60,000 mortgage so if we paid off your
mortgage you'd have $25,000 in the bank
and no mortgage yep and you can make it
easily on 60 grand if your guy if your
hours get cut that far yeah okay I would
do that yeah
okay you know the cash doesn't give you
the cash doesn't carry you a play any
place that you're gonna have to go and
you get 25,000 bucks laying there still
which is a nice you know it's a nice
chunk that's like six months of income
for if you lost all your income from off
the sixty anyway so yeah I mean if the
math seems to make sense to me and
that's what we're doing so good question
thanks for joining us
so that exercise is a good one for a
bunch of you that are facing crap out
there right now okay what is the
probability what's the percent chance in
your mind that this is this something's
going to happen I'm not talking about
vague worrying because you're panicking
and you're hysterical because you've
been watching the news I'm talking about
really where you work what is gonna be
the problem that you're gonna face and
start projecting you know this is like I
think the worst thing can happen this is
probably what's going to happen
somewhere in there and start building
out your budget based on that and
deciding whether you're going to stop
your baby steps and build up cash
because you got a storm coming some of
you don't have much of a storm coming
some of you got a hurricane coming